[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 avec Michael midoro bonjour bonjour
à voir avec vous les grands titres de
l'actualité dans quelques instants mais
au sommaire de cette émission et bien on
parlera d'abord de l'ouverture d'une
antenne de la très célèbre école des
agricultures et s'est ouverte à
Guyancourt l'inauguration a lieu
vendredi dernier et on va vous parler
dans quelques instants avec vous
Fabienne
la responsable du campus de de cette
école on parlera on va ouvrir une grande
page cinéma et c'est pas mal après tout
on est on est mercredi d'abord il y aura
les conseils de Vincent Mirabel que vous
connaissez il y a un pro et un prof de
du cinéma et qui donnera toutes les
bonnes raisons de regarder ou de revoir
ou de voir le très grand film de
Jean-Jacques Annaud Stalingrad et puis
nous recevrons Luc Bocan qui est le
directeur du ciné 7 d'énancourt et avec
lui on s'interrogera sur le fait que les
Français ne vont plus au cinéma les
Yvelines non plus un peu moins en tout
cas qu'il n'y allait avant
on ne vous donnera aussi quelques
conseils c'est vrai qu'il y a encore la
pénurie d'essence ça s'améliore un peu
mais c'est pas fini et bien avec un
instructeur de de l'Institut Beltoise
qui est à trappe on demandera comment
consommer un peu moins d'essence et puis
dans quelques minutes nous serons en
ligne avec Xavier thévenat Xavier
Thévenard a lancé aujourd'hui même son
défi sportif et écologique 250 km autour
de Paris pour sensibiliser sensibiliser
la pratique sportive et co-responsable
alors thévenar ne fait pas que que
courir il va sensibiliser les
populations et notamment les jeunes sur
l'importance du sport au service de la
perspective de la protection de la
nature avec nous aussi Nicolas dandry
bonsoir
vous êtes dans le fauteuil mais avec
vous on va quand même parler d'un truc
passionnant de technologie ouais de
technologie de 5g parce que durant les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste qui ont eu lieu ce weekend à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines d'ailleurs il
y a le parasyclisme qui commence et on
va en parler je crois et bien pendant
ces championnats du monde et bien ils
ont testé Nokia avec ses partenaires à
tester l'enceinte sportive connectée
c'est à dire que le vélodrome national
était connecté à la 5G et vous allez
voir ça permet beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de choses vous allez nous
raconter ça dans dans quelques instants
mais d'abord ça c'est une grande
première pour moi je suis très je suis
ravi de faire ça je vais me déguiser en
Miss Météo c'est-à-dire c'est très très
sexy de dire miss météo en Monsieur
Météo pour vous donner la météo de
demain vous voulez savoir quel temps il
va faire beau vous allez voir il fait
beau il fait beau dès le matin alors il
y a des températures voyez entre 15 et
20 degrés non 15 euh 15 16 degrés le
matin c'est bah enfin c'est pas mal
c'est un peu nuage le matin
ça va s'améliorer tout au long de la
journée et l'après-midi on est dans les
20 degrés et puis du soleil un peu plus
partout dans les Yvelines donc c'est
bien peut-être ou sur l'île de loisirs
on va faire les on va voir les titres de
l'actualité et on commence par l'image
du jour ben justement on en parlait
l'image du jour c'est le soleil c'est
les images ensoleillées des Yvelines et
oui Patrice des records de température
ont été abattu cette semaine du
vingtaine de degrés partout dans les
Yvelines avec des ressentis qui vont
jusqu'à 25 degrés c'est du jamais vu
pour un mois d'octobre alors deuxième
petite c'est la grève il y avait encore
une journée de grève et surtout dans les
transports comment ça s'est passé alors
aujourd'hui la circulation a été
compliqué dans les secteurs de Trappes
Versailles Rambouillet avec un
conducteur sur deux la SNCF prévoit un
retour progressif à la normale demain
sur la plupart des lignes de train au
niveau de l'essence les fils d'attente
reste interminables en Île-de-France
plus de 30% des stations sont à sec
après trois semaines de les grévistes
des sites de Total énergie devaient se
prononcer ce midi sur la suite de la
grève verdict trois raffineries sont
encore en grève une raffinerie lève la
grève alors une question importante
c'est la cybersécurité justement ce
matin il y a eu l'ouverture d'horizon
cyber le rendez-vous francilien sur la
cybersécurité le but vulgariser et
montrer l'état de la connaissance sur la
cybersécurité pour Jean-Michel fourgouse
président de l'agglomération de 50 ans
en Yvelines c'est aussi l'occasion pour
les entreprises de se rencontrer pour
participer à la meilleure sécurisation
de notre territoire il est question que
Saint-Quentin soit aussi dans les faire
de Laurence bien sûr de l'accompagnement
de nos entreprises de nos chercheurs
bien sûr pour pour protéger on a 17000
entreprises on est là aussi pour les
protéger avec nos moyens bien sûr et
avec nous toutes les entreprises
spécialisées qu'on a la chance d'avoir
sur Saint-Quentin donc évidemment ce
thème est central et les Français
doivent comprendre que en termes de
souveraineté s'ils veulent garder une
souveraineté il faut que la France et
une force de défense en si bien sécurité
opérationnel au meilleur niveau mondial
organisé par le hub cyber and security
de system systématique l'événement
regroupé une centaine de personnes alors
il est bon Dieu cyclisme le la fin de la
semaine dernière et là c'est les
Mondiaux de paracyclisme qui ouvre leur
porte demain exactement Patrice 230
athlètes sont attendus pour tenter de
décrocher 61 médailles rendez-vous
déterminant ces championnats du monde
sur piste représente une grande
répétition générale avant les Jeux à
paralympiques de Paris 2024 il se
dérouleront du jeudi 20 octobre dimanche
23 octobre et l'équipe de France de
parasitisme compte bien rafler des
titres avec 18 sportifs engagés très
bien et on reste dans le sport avec
Poissy qui est qualifié pour le septième
tour de la Coupe de France et qui
rencontrera
Oissel je ne sais pas où est Wassel mais
je crois que c'est dans l'Est de la
France je me trompe pas et le match se
tiendra le 30 octobre à 14h30 sur le
terrain du club municipal sportif doit
celle en Seine-Maritime je me suis
complètement trompé Seine-Maritime les
picia khi affront les océiens évolue en
National 3 en cas de qualification pour
le 8e tour ce sera un déplacement face
au vainqueur du match
US ttgam et FC Loon Plage bien sûr
encore les amateurs mais on monte
facilement au niveau effectivement je
rappelle que Versailles
éliminé face au Red Star une belle
équipe une équipe de même niveau de
national alors on a eu le l'image du
jour c'était le soleil quel est le
chiffre du jour cela représente
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
il permet l'exécutif d'adopter
directement un texte de loi sans
concerter l'Assemblée nationale et
Isabelle Borg la première ministre a
décidé d'y recourir suite aux multiples
débats sans résultat de cette semaine
les députés n'arrivent pas à se mettre
d'accord sur le projet loi de finance ce
2023 au total 3400 amendements ont été
déposés par l'opposition et bien
justement puisque vous parlez de 49-3 on
va en parler avec Charles Rodwell qui
est député de la première la
transcription des Yvelines députés
Renaissance Charles Rodwell bonjour je
voudrais savoir d'abord qu'est-ce que
c'est cette procédure de 49.3 avant
chaque outil qu'on utilise il faut un
budget pour la France en l'année 2023
aujourd'hui nous devons consolider ou
mettre en ensemble deux priorités qui
ont été mises en avant par le
gouvernement et par notre majorité
depuis plusieurs semaines un la
protection des Français de le
rétablissement de nos finances publiques
qui est aussi en fait finalement une
forme de protection parce que on veut
qui est le moins d'être possible qui
pèse sur les générations futures et on
veut reconstituer notre trésorerie et si
je puis dire public pour faire face à
des chocs futurs qui pourraient être
venir
l'idée que de ce de ce projet de loi de
finances 2023 c'est de garantir un
budget qui soit solide pour nous donner
les moyens financiers de répondre à ces
deux objectifs tant pour les ménages
avec notamment le bouclier tarifaire qui
va protéger de l'ensemble des ménages en
France mais c'est aussi protégé nos
entreprises notamment nos plus petites
entreprises et bien sûr tout le travail
qu'on fait aujourd'hui pour limiter le
choc sur les collectivités locales dans
le cas de cette crise énergétique mais
alors qu'est-ce qui a rendu cette
utilisation du 49-3 à votre sauce
nécessaire
ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui c'est que
du côté de la majorité et du côté de
certaines oppositions il y a vraiment
une volonté de co-construire ensemble
des députés qui ont vraiment
d'excellentes propositions pour
améliorer le texte tant sur la
protection que sur la dépense publique
mais ce que l'on constate aussi c'est
que les gars malheureusement une partie
des oppositions qui veut vraiment jouer
le blocage le rassemblement national et
une grande partie de la nupesse ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas jouer
ce projet de loi de finance 2023 sur un
coup de dés le 49-3 c'est un outil comme
un autre qui existe qui a des moyens de
limiter que gouvernement ne peut pas
utiliser à temps et à travers il ne peut
utiliser que sur certains textes pour
faire passer notamment le budget pour la
France pour protéger les Français et
pour réduire la dépense publique
alors quel texte doit être soumis au
49-3 est-ce que c'est le texte initial
du budget qui a été présenté par le
gouvernement où est-ce que c'est un
texte qui doit comprendre les
amendements qui ont déjà été votés
revenir au texte initial ce serait
finalement annulé toutes les heures que
nous avons eu de débats dans l'émission
et je peux vous dire alors souvent on
partage les moments de combat de cris
mais j'encourage vraiment chacun d'entre
ceux qui nous regardent actuellement
d'aller voir son site de l'Assemblée
nationale tous les débats de fonds qu'on
a eu sur beaucoup de questions la
fiscalité l'accompagnement des
entreprises l'accompagnement des
agriculteurs hier soir pendant très
longs moments sur lequel parfois il est
positions oppositions fortes 2 sur
lequel il y a un consensus et donc il
serait illogique il ne serait pas
logique
que le gouvernement
ignore la plupart des modifications
qu'on a fait sur ce texte il y a des
modifications très saines apportées par
l'Assemblée nationale sur ce texte qui
l'améliore de manière très concrète et
de manière très forte c'est la raison
pour laquelle je soutiens tout à fait
Bruno Le Maire et Gabriel Attal
lorsqu'ils expliquent que oui le texte
qui sera présenté en 49-3 sera un texte
qui aura été modifié par nos débats à
l'Assemblée nationale
merci beaucoup charles-andouel pour cet
éclairage je rappelle que vous êtes
député renaissance de la première
circonscription des Yvelines puis on va
vous recontactera peut-être d'ici
quelques jours pour la pour la motion de
censure parce que je pense que c'est la
suite logique de l'utilisation du 49-3
Nicolas dandry
émerveiller parce que les technologies
chinoises effectivement 56
particulièrement
disons on va élargir 50 ans ça va
jusqu'au plateau de Saclay puisque Nokia
c'est plus largement installé aussi sur
le plateau et on va prendre on va
revenir sur les Championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste durant 5 jours la
compétition de compétition et bah le
vélo de drone national s'est transformé
en enceinte sportive connectée c'est
dans le cadre du projet de Stadium Lab
c'est un projet donc emoniait par Nokia
Nokia vous savez c'est une
multinationale spécialisée dans les
télécommunications et notamment dans le
déploiement du réseau en 5G
finlandais finlandais et donc l'objectif
de notre Nokia et ses partenaires et
bien c'est d'améliorer l'expérience des
spectateurs dans les stades mais aussi
des téléspectateurs devant leur
télévision et à ce propos on écoute
Stéphane Holbert le directeur des
partenariats Europe chez nos cahiers
nous explique comment fonctionne tout
cela d'accord on déploie un réseau 5G
privé donc c'est c'est un serveur qui
correspond à réseau mobile ou un
opérateur vers des millions d'abonnés et
ici on gère quelques milliers d'abonnés
comme vous pouvez le voir sur sur la
salle technique on déploie ensuite des
Smalls des petites cellules on en a
trois sur le site puis ils sont dans les
ondes mini métriques qui permettent
d'accéder à des très très haut débit
pour de la télé à 4K 8k mais également
des latence est faible pour pouvoir
piloter en temps réel ces images et
avoir cette passion et cette immersion
totale alors là on vient de voir toutes
les technologies qui permettent la
connexion en 5G au sein du vélo de Rome
grâce à la 5G et bien écoutez par
exemple les journalistes photographes
qui sont présents sur l'événement qui
photographie les pistards sur la piste
on va prendre l'exemple d'un journaliste
de l'agence de France Presse et bien dès
qu'il prend sa photo il peut directement
l'envoyer et mettre la photo à
disposition à l'agence grâce à la 5G
autre chose qui est possible c'est pour
les téléspectateurs qui sont dans les
tribunes et les spectateurs les
spectateurs dans les tribunes
téléspectateurs
après alors pour les spectateurs en
tribune qui sont dans le vélo de drone
et bien grâce à leur smartphone il se
connecte à la 5G ils ont accès à une
application qui s'appelle vogo et grâce
à cette application ils peuvent choisir
l'angle de vue de la course qui est en
train de se dérouler sous vos yeux donc
c'est à dire si vous voulez des émotions
mais c'est c'est marrant parce que
finalement les gens ils vont aller voir
un spectacle et puis ils vont être sur
leur smartphone c'est quand même
étonnant comme les étudiants à la pause
mais c'est finalement c'est
l'amélioration de
l'expérience de spectateur et tout ça
vous y pensez Patrice aujourd'hui les
perspectives des Jeux Olympiques bien
sûr voilà c'est améliorer ce spectacle
je veux dire simplement c'est
intéressant parce que c'est vrai qu'on
est à la fois dans la vie sur les écrans
en même temps aujourd'hui oui c'est ça
on a déjà accès hein vous voyez par
exemple pour le Tour de France les
spectateurs qui sont en bord de route
aujourd'hui on sait que notamment France
Télévisions développe une application où
on peut choisir la moto c'est à dire
qu'on regarde juste la course avec la
moto numéro 1 qui est en tête de peloton
ou l'arrière de la course enfin voilà
c'est des choses qui existent déjà même
d'ailleurs pratiquement exactement la 5G
dans le vélo et donc on écoute encore
une fois Stéphane olbert qui nous décrit
un peu tout ce qui est possible de faire
autour de cela
pour les spectateurs dans la salle pour
pouvoir avoir des prises de vue
différentes de du Y pour avoir des
ambiances de son dégradins du centre de
piste en direct et avoir une immersion
totale avec ses sportifs préférés
alors là on vient donc d'écouter Nokia
parmi les partenaires avec qui travaille
Nokia et bien il y a xemotion xdmotion
entreprise
donc pour être précis il est à 50 ans en
Yvelines et puis bah c'est les
innovations dans la captation
audiovisuelle et bien la 5G permet de
pousser plus loin encore les innovations
dans la captation audiovisuelle on
écoute Benoît Dantin le fondateur de
cette entreprise qui nous donne deux
exemples de matériel qui ont été
utilisés durant ces Championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste on a des
caméras ce qu'on appelle des remote
caméra tout simple qui sont installés
dans le stade qui sont pilotés à
distance déjà la 5G nous apporte la
fluidité une latence extrêmement réduite
et surtout une grande qualité d'image
d'un partenariat donc avec Eurovision et
orange on a donc décidé de mettre deux
caméras cette fois sur le système X fly
cablecam une qui va servir pour
effectivement l'intégralité du live et
une deuxième innovante en 5G qui est une
caméra donc gyrostabilisée avec c'est à
dire que l'image est très stable avec
une caméra 360 degrés qui est
retransmise en direct sur l'application
de rangée 20 grâce à la 5G de Nokia vous
avez vu cette câble cam c'est formidable
c'est lui qui a inventé ça c'est lui qui
a inventé ça et puis grâce à la 5G
sur la cablecam dernière chose et ça je
vous invite à le découvrir parce que le
skyco le prochain caeco qui est diffusé
le 28 novembre pas ce vendredi mais le
vendredi prochain et bien on reviendra
dessus et vous allez pouvoir découvrir
dans ce sky éco le dernier outil de xD
motion c'est une caméra en 8k oui vous
avez bien entendu Patrice c'est de la 8k
360 degrés et ça ça permet c'est une
première c'est la 5G qui rend possible
cela de diffuser mais l'image d'une
telle qualité c'était pas possible avant
la 5G le permet et ça c'est un travail
avec Orange pareil pour donner une
d'autres vision parce que cette caméra
était juste au dessus de l'air centrale
et vous pouvez voir toute la piste image
8k 3060 degrés c'est vendredi prochain
vendredi 28 novembre dans le skygo
octobre 28 octobre
et je vois que vous en garder un peu
sous le coude pour ce qu'il y ait quoi
alors on va parler dans un instant avec
vous avec de l'école supérieure des
agriculteurs mais auparavant on va
peut-être un petit peu continuer dans la
technologie si je puis dire mais dans la
technologie de santé puisque
vient de on va aller faire un petit
détour par le séné puisque à l'hôpital
du Chesnay peut-être plus privée du CD
vient d'ouvrir un service de cardiologie
de jour avec un scanner tout à fait
incroyable regardez l'Hôpital Privé
Parly 2 à son hôpital de jour de
cardiologie créée depuis le 15 septembre
2022 cette unité de 17 lips prend en
charge des examens de type
coronarographie ou encore
angioplastiques coronaire cet accueil a
reçu son 100e patient le jeudi 13
octobre au Chesnay Rocancourt un des
principaux objectifs ayant amené à
l'ouverture de ce service d'hôpital de
jour et de permettre une fluidification
du circuit de prise en charge du patient
au sein de la clinique
de permettre aux patients de de
concentrer ces rendez-vous de prise en
charge sur une seule journée depuis
septembre l'établissement a fait
l'acquisition d'un scanner coronaire de
dernière génération un matériel
permettant une acquisition accélérée
afin d'éviter les flots liés au
mouvement des patients lors d'un examen
il est très très bon en cardiologie
puisque en un quart de seconde on arrive
à faire une acquisition sur la totalité
des coronaires c'est un examen qui est
peu invasif
qui est une valeur diagnostic très
intéressante pour pour tous les patients
de cardio l'Hôpital Privé Parly 2
accueille un service de cardiologie et
radiologie vasculaire interventionnelle
cette unité prend en charge les formes
les plus sévères d'urgence cardiologique
on a beaucoup de matériel parce que nous
on opère pas donc tout se passe en
percutanée en passant par les artères
des jambes donc on a énormément de
matériel et chaque matériel est dédié au
millimètre près qui correspond aux
artères qu'on va devoir travailler il y
a quelques années une cour
normographique ça se faisait sur deux
jours dans spécialisation une enjeu
plastique je vois trois quatre jours
maintenant grâce à
la technicité du matériel on peut
traiter la plupart des patients
ambulatoire ce qui permet de limiter les
durées d'hospitalisation les maladies
cardiovasculaires sont la première cause
de mortalité dans le monde et la
deuxième en France après les cancers
elles sont à l'origine d'environ 140 000
décès par an
que je rappelle est toujours à l'hôpital
privé de parler de parce qu'il essaye
tous les tous les matériels donc Julien
faut rentrer maintenant c'est fini
Fabienne alors on va parler de cette
école supérieure des agricultures je
deviens des agriculture parce que ça a
été longtemps l'École supérieure de
l'agriculture d'agriculture même
effectivement l'école a voulu changer de
logo parce que c'est vraiment une école
qui s'occupe de toutes les productions
que ce soit les productions végétales
les productions animales tout ce qui est
l'industrie agroalimentaire mais aussi
toutes les questions environnementales
du coup on a étendu notre logo aux
agricultures et puis on s'intéresse
aussi à toutes les problématiques des
filières qui veulent bien comment
travailler en bonne intelligence avec
l'environnement alors vous êtes
responsable du campus de l'ESA je je
rappelle et je me rappelle que vous avez
une carrière d'enseignante avant du VSQ
et vous avez rejoint
ça alors il faut raconter un bout de
cette école qui est assez ancienne elle
a été créée je crois à la fin du 19e
siècle à Angers elle est d'ailleurs le
siège principal est toujours à Angers
tout à fait la maison mère reste à
Angers et donc là c'est un établissement
fille un campus secondaire qu'on ouvre
sur 50 ans à Guyancourt qui s'appelle le
sa pari
tout à fait il y a combien je crois à
peu près un peu moins de 3000 étudiants
à peu près
d'étudiants
3200 étudiants donc une cinquantaine de
formations et à peu près un tiers
d'étudiants qui suivent le diplôme
ingénieur donc ça c'est le diplôme
historique de l'école
ingénieur agronome
donc on recrute les élèves post-bac en
fait et on les accompagne pendant 5 ans
alors après on fait aussi des admissions
parallèles il y a des élèves qui ont un
BTS qui peuvent rejoindre la troisième
année on a des élèves qui ont aussi des
licences qui peuvent rejoindre la
quatrième année donc il y a beaucoup de
passerelles maintenant dans
l'enseignement sup toute façon c'est
obligatoire d'avoir des passerelles
comment ça s'est fait ensuite avec
l'agglomération
[Musique]
donc tous les ans on étudie ce qu'on
appelle les prospects chez nous pour
savoir d'où ils viennent et on se rend
compte il y en a 30 % qui viennent
d'îles de France et en fait on ne
concrétise pas avec ces 30% à la fin on
en a plus que 5 6% qui viennent à Angers
et probablement la principale raison
c'est la distance donc du coup ben on
vient on décide de venir alors il y
avait deux questions dans votre dans
votre question donc pourquoi
Saint-Quentin il y a eu plusieurs c'est
un projet qui qui est
pas eu d'appel d'Off il y a eu un
accompagnement avec avec un cabinet
enquête spécialisé dans l'enseignement
supérieur et donc ce cabinet a proposé
en fait plusieurs sites et le site idéal
qui est apparu c'était 50 ans
exactement et il y a quand même une
étendue voilà proche de Paris proche de
Paris-Saclay aussi et puis bon bah
l'accueil sur le territoire et
formidable donc comme bon voilà ce qui
était présent à l'inauguration ont pu le
constater
parce que vous n'êtes pas loin de la
vallée de chevaux de la plaine de
Versailles bien sûr donc les Yvelines
chez vous vous avez une idée
une cinquantaine de %. voilà donc
du Lion vous attendez
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est que
c'est une plus petite promotion
qu'arranger à Angers on tourne autour de
130 jusqu'à 180 là c'est des promotions
par année pour ingénieur agronome de 50
étudiants on ouvre aussi un deuxième
diplôme qui a un Bachelor donc là c'est
un diplôme en trois ans en agroécologie
et système immunitaire voilà on duplique
de formation
ce diplôme est nouveau pour les
highlighter et donc 50 par année donc
comme on a deux formations ça nous fait
sans par année et donc dans trois ans on
sera à 300 donc c'est une école à taille
humaine et je le disais au début de de
l'entretien c'est vrai qu'on peut penser
que l'enseignement agricole a beaucoup
évolué dans les 20 dernières années oui
tout à fait alors pourquoi
l'environnement enfin il y a des choses
dont on
bien sûr d'abord il y a plus de bouche à
nourrir qu'avant il y a moins d'hommes
sur le terrain il y a eu une réduction
des espaces et agricoles et en plus il y
a les machines qui sont arrivées donc
l'école elle s'adapte on dit souvent que
c'est l'école aussi des transitions dans
tous les domaines que je vous citer tout
à l'heure donc en permanence l'école
fait appel à des professionnels pour
s'adapter aux filières et aux
prématiques des filières
à Grenoble moi je pense directement aux
ingénieurs qui travaillent avec
notamment dans les chambres
d'agriculture il y a des dans les
ingénieurs qui sont dans les chambres
d'agriculture qui a cherché les
agriculteurs où il y a aussi les draps
je pense que le bon résumé alors mon
directeur de thèse était ingénieur
agronome il me disait il m'avait dit
j'ai fait ça parce qu'on m'a dit que ça
mènerait à tout et donc effectivement
ingénieur agronome vous pouvez tout
faire donc ça va de la recherche ça va à
l'innovation mais aussi dans la
production ça va dans le conseil mais ça
peut faire aussi du mar ça peut aller
sur les marchés internationaux de négoce
etc donc c'est vraiment un métier qui
mène à tout
est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut encore
s'inscrire oui tout à fait alors c'est
notre première année donc on a ouvert à
la rentrée en septembre 2022 donc il
nous reste encore des places donc là
faut prendre contact avec vos contacter
sur le site web et puis ensuite surtout
c'est l'année prochaine donc voilà
et encore
oui il faut le bac donc c'est post-bac
alors comme je vous dis après on fait
des admissions secondaires donc l'année
prochaine avec nos premières années de
cette année qui seront deuxième année on
sera ravis d'accueillir éventuellement
des gens qui souhaitent changer
d'orientation ça c'est tout à fait
possible et d'ailleurs ça apporte une
mixité qui est très intéressante donc
voilà si on veut s'inscrire il y a un
site internet je voulais quand même
peut-être pour venir découvrir à l'école
on va faire des journées portes ouvertes
donc on commence assez tôt le 15
novembre avec des portes des journées
portes ouvertes virtuelle donc voilà
vous avez la date et sinon en présentiel
le samedi 3 décembre et le samedi 11
février donc le campus est à Guyancourt
et donc les portes seront ouvertes pour
sur votre site les premières mais après
les autres on revient à du présentiel
voilà il faut les deux maintenant
peut-être une dernière question on voit
les tensions qui a sur différents sur le
marché du travail mais c'est dans
différents secteurs est-ce que le
secteur agricole est aussi concerné
alors je parle pas des agriculteurs
parce que ça on le sait que c'est un
vrai véritable problème certains
agriculteurs qui ont du mal à
transmettre leur exploitation mais dans
les secteurs d'ingénierie agricole
est-ce que il y a des tensions pas du
tout c'est un système qui est
extrêmement porteur avec une très forte
employabilité il faut je crois que c'est
98% de nos élèves n'ont pas soutenu leur
mémoire de fin d'études qui sont déjà
recrutés et
il y a des besoins d'ingénieurs dans
toute la France et dans ce domaine
évidemment très porteur et c'est très
intéressant parce que pour les stages
c'est la même chose les élèves
choisissent leur qui est assez rare dans
les formations et donc dès que je me
déplace quelque part on me demandait
est-ce que on pourrait en avoir en stage
c'est des élèves qui sont très reconnus
aussi
de métiers où on recherche des gens
formés notamment des gens bien formés
comme ils le peuvent être à l'école
supérieure des agricultures vous
viendrez nous en parler aux autres ça
sert bien qu'on fasse une chronique
agricole
avec plaisir merci infiniment
l'école supérieure
des agricultures
Michael si je vous dis Véronique Chaplin
ça vous dit quelque chose je crois que
je vais dire si break
c'est une association qui a créé et
une trentaine d'années et qui vient à
l'aide de jeunes gens parfois de milieux
un peu défavorisés pour les initiés au
sport ils peuvent rencontrer des
sportifs de très haut niveau et il une
édition une nouvelle édition de type
break c'était en fin de semaine dernière
vendredi dernier et de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
de loisir de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et Céline Charles et Gabriel Gauthier
était sur place un événement solidaire
au profit de l'association SOS gazelle
qui soutient les enfants à travers
l'éducation le sport et la santé au golf
de l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines plusieurs
activités ont lieu à l'occasion du
tibrac gourmand parmi elles des ateliers
multisports à destinations des jeunes
120 élèves de quatre écoles des Yvelines
ont été encadrées par des sportifs de
haut niveau des médecins du sport ou
encore des athlètes olympiques objectif
découvrir toutes les vertus du sport à
travers les conseils des professionnels
la boxe ça génère toujours un peu
d'intérêt en donner mais surtout pas en
prendre
toujours toujours être capable de se
protéger
[Musique]
comment on fait
de la maison découvrir plusieurs sports
après on pourra en faire plus enfin si
on par exemple on sait pas quel sport
faire après on peut découvrir et on
brancher ça nous fait apprendre aussi
des choses plusieurs corps de métiers
étaient également présentés aux enfants
on a répondu présent à SOS gazelles pour
justement présenter ce qui était notre
métier par l'intermédiaire de quatre
ateliers notre but aujourd'hui c'est de
faire envie à ses enfants pour essayer
de de les intéresser à ce qu'on fait et
pourquoi pas un jour il fasse partie de
nos équipes
une machine une simulation plutôt sur
sur le cas casser je crois et ça
entraîne pour pour le maniement du truc
après l'effort le réconfort un concours
Top Chef était organisé avec un jury
composé notamment de chef yvelin et
sportifs invités étaient chargés de
créer un apéro sain avec des aliments
locaux il y a un joli événement où on
fait des trucs pour les gamins et SOS
Gazelle est présent c'est les gens qu'on
voit souvent donc c'était cool de
pouvoir de l'appareil la journée s'est
achevée sur une vente aux enchères
maillot de match de Messi signé raquette
Roland Garros ou encore maillot de rugby
du Stade Français au total c'est 20000
euros qui ont été récoltés
de province de dons c'est pas mal 20000
euros et je crois avec 10
maillots vendus
un maillot de Mbappé vous l'auriez
acheté combien il y a un maillot de
Messi
moi c'est un maillot de Dan Carter si
vous me trouvez un maillot de Dan Carter
très peu de temps avant PSG Nice
vous vous êtes marseillais donc moi je
pense que je l'aurais acheté je l'aurais
acheté quand c'est quand même Kylian
Mbappe j'aurais acheté allez 1500 euros
je crois et 5400 celui de Messi
Mbappé il est en train d'écrire ça les
gens mais je pense que ça va les prix
vont s'envoler encore plus dans quelques
années je pense que c'est un bon achat
et vous serez la star la star
je pense que ça serait Pelé je pense on
va le rappeler
grand ouvrage néo-zélandais mais dans le
rugby vous allez le voir en
Nouvelle-Zélande on va essayer alors je
vous avais promis Xavier thévenar qui
est qui fait son son tour de
l'Île-de-France
un tour sportif et écologique en même
temps je crois qu'on a quelques
problèmes de liaison donc on va essayer
de rétablir ça on aura peut-être un
petit peu plus tard
dans cette émission pour l'instant vous
avez trouvé de l'essence vous
la semaine dernière j'ai réussi j'ai
fait quand même une heure et demie de
queue c'était au carrefour Chambourcy
pour pas le citer j'ai fait une heure et
demie de queue mais j'ai quand même
réussi à avoir des sens mais là je
commence à rêver un peu sur la réserve
il faut faire attention mais vraiment
incroyable moi j'ai pas fait que je suis
arrivé directement à la station j'ai pu
me servir et repartir ça a duré 5
minutes il va lui lundi soir 22h dans la
campagne yvelinoise moule la ville de
Maule et bien je suis passé devant un
magasin
il y avait personne je me suis servi je
suis parti
d'être ravita et il y avait de l'essence
je ne suis pas disais alors il y a une
queue de deux heures
alors justement on s'est dit ça serait
peut-être pas mal de donner des conseils
aux autobilistes ça va reprendre mais ça
va prendre encore un peu de temps pour
pour dépenser un peu moins d'essence et
on s'est adressé à Franck brégion Franck
région qui est d'instructeur au centre
au circuit Beltoise évolution et c'est
un spécialiste de l'éco-conduite et
voilà alors Franck région bonjour et je
voudrais vous savoir voilà quels sont
vos conseils pour essayer d'économiser
le plus possible l'essence dans les
voitures pour consommer le moins
possible faut déjà avoir une attitude
zen qu'il faut pas s'énerver ne pas se
laisser influencer par les autres
puisque la conduite économique c'est
nécessite un petit peu de gérer les
inerties et donc les espaces et parfois
il y aura besoin de laisser d'espace de
l'espace notamment quand c'est un roule
mal puisque ça évite de
subir les élèves fréquents des personnes
qui sont devant nous sur un périple
parisien par exemple et l'idée quand on
met de la place par rapport au véhicule
qui sont devant nous donc du coup c'est
limite les erreurs parce que ce qui
consomme le plus c'est de partir de zéro
et de redémarrer quand le feu au loin il
est rouge ça vaut le coup parfois de
lever le pied un tout petit peu plus tôt
comme ça pendant ce temps là le feu
passe au vert et justement ça permet ça
permet de se donner la chance de ne pas
avoir à s'arrêter de continuer à évoluer
justement avec un minimum d'arrêt et
pendant ce temps là en fait on consomme
zéro ce temps que le temps que le régime
le temps que le régime moteur en fait
continue à descendre on consomme zéro
puisque maintenant on a tous des
véhicules avec des moteurs injection on
consomme 0 ça permet justement bah de
profiter de rien consommer d'avancer
quand même et d'espérer que le feu vert
s'allume et donc de pouvoir relancer la
voiture d'ailleurs de plus en plus de
boîtes automatiques propose en fait un
mode roue libre ce qui permet en fait de
pouvoir lâcher l'accélérateur encore
plus tôt alors je sais bien qu'il y a
des personnes des personnes qui
m'entendent vont certainement dire oui
mais quand on est en mode roue libre le
moteur tourne au ralenti c'est vrai
amateur qui tourne au ralenti consomme
de l'ordre d'environ un demi litre à
l'heure mais par rapport en fait à
l'endroit où on va lâcher l'accélérateur
notamment très tôt ça permet souvent
aussi de d'être très bénéficiaires
voilà merci beaucoup Franck région c'est
intéressant parce que le circuit
Beltoise qui apprend à conduire
rapidement avec avec des voitures de
sport
c'est que maintenant il y a cette
section déco conduite c'est-à-dire
en effet les gens se demandent comment
dépenser un peu moins d'essence c'est
dans l'air du temps c'est dans le temps
alors évidemment c'est bien de conduire
assez souplement d'anticiper un petit
peu si on reprend un peu ce qu'il dit de
d'éviter de d'éviter de s'arrêter de
repartir parce que ça c'est terrible le
plus et puis on le voit très bien
notamment à Paris là où on consomme le
plus c'est quand on s'arrête et qu'on
redémarre d'où cette problématique de
peut-être de limiter la circulation dans
Paris enfin je suppose que vous avez ce
sujet parce que vous êtes à Paris mais
discuter enfin le projet un petit peu
avant il dit aussi rouler très doucement
n'est pas forcément
signe de d'économie d'essence
entre 50 et 80 ça va les limitations à
30 c'est terrible paraît-il voilà pour
la consommation et je crois que enfin on
ira voir un peu peut-être c'est Beltoise
comment comment ça se passe elle est des
cours qui donne et parce que je crois
qu'il donne aussi des cours pour les
pour les voitures électriques parce que
là aussi ça demande de savoir comment ne
pas trop dépenser d'électricité quand
dans une voiture électrique parce que si
vous tombez en panne dans une voiture
électrique
alors on va ouvrir maintenant la page
culture la page cinéma
[Musique]
alors on va commencer par une page
cinéma de cinéma classique avec le choix
du prof ou soit du Pro vous le
connaissez bien c'est Vincent Mirabel
qui a notamment écrit le cinéma pour les
nuls donc c'est de quoi il parle
très très bien le cinéma et là il va
donner toutes les raisons de voir
ou de revoir un très très bon film qui
est Stalingrad de mon avis Jean-Jacques
Annaud Vincent les Russes sont en guerre
pas contre l'Ukraine contre le Troisième
Reich allemand nous sommes fin 1942
début 1943 et cette bataille la bataille
de Stalingrad va marquer les esprits et
faire basculer la future victoire des
Alliés
Jean-Jacques Annaud le grand réalisateur
de La Guerre du Feu est plus récemment
de Notre-Dame brûle va réaliser un film
de guerre de prestige
deux grands acteurs d'un côté Jude Law
de l'autre côté l'Américain et Harris
[Musique]
qui sont extrêmement malins l'un et
l'autre pour essayer d'abattre leur
adversaire vont se livrer un combat
épique qui va nous tenir en haleine
pendant plus de deux heures et l'on ne
voit jamais le temps passé c'est un film
captivant plus fort à mon avis pour
représenter les sniper que le film
américain sniper de Clint Eastwood
film de guerre film de thriller à
suspense vous ne vous embêterez pas une
seconde
bon voyage
merci Vincent
un fou du détail c'est vrai qu'il
regarde que ce que tous les détails
soient exactement authentiques enfin
comme il les veut je sais qu'il avait
passé des mois et des mois quand il
avait tourné l'amant à faire repeindre
le bateau qu'on voit dans l'amant de la
bonne couleur enfin donc elle fait
peindre encore plein etc et une anecdote
qui est plus amusante sur lui ce que il
a commencé sur des avec des films
publicitaires et un jour il a fait une
publicité je sais plus pour quelle
marque c'était où il y avait un singe
et ça a été très compliqué à tourner
parce que le singe qui était d'une
guenon en réalité est tombé amoureuse de
lui et donc elle devenait dingue dès
qu'il était
dans le champ et il a raconté donc ça
avait duré des ça faisait absolument
impossible de filmer quand il était là
donc c'était comme quelque chose
d'incroyable c'est vous l'avez vu
top 20 des films
les réseaux sur les sniper se combat
entre les sniper et absolument
incroyable comme vous le disiez tout est
très réaliste et puis alors on devrait
parler dans quelques instants il est pas
encore arrivé j'espère qu'il va arriver
avec le directeur du cinéma 7 de
d'Élancourt mais il est un peu dans les
embouteillages pour l'instant non je
voulais lui parler avec lui de faire de
la crise du cinéma puisque vous savez
que la fréquentation
des cinémas est la plus basse depuis 40
ans actuellement voilà on dit beaucoup
que c'est les gens depuis la covid qui
veulent plus aller au cinéma
qui a la concurrence aussi des
plateformes il y a peut-être d'autres
raisons j'espère que j'espère qu'il va
qu'il va venir Luc Bocan assez vite pour
qu'on puisse en parler en attendant je
vous propose de nous intéresser à un
film qu'on a découvert à Cannes c'est je
crois il y a 2 ans c'est l'âge d'or
alors là je dors pas celui de Bunel mais
celui de Jana souroux et on prend
régulièrement des nouvelles de ce film
qui continuent à faire ça sa carrière
bah voilà les les dernières nouvelles
nous envoyer une sorte de carte postale
quoi
moi je suis actrice
je joue au théâtre mais mon rêve
c'est le grand écran un film hommage au
Saint-Tropez des années 60 une comédie
romantique sur l'art qu'il célèbre la
vie et l'amitié l'âge d'or et le premier
long-métrage de Genas sur rue projeté au
Festival de Cannes en 2019 le film
poursuit son parcours sur le marché
international en naviguant de festival
en festival dernier en date
l'incontournable ciné Quest en
Californie
c'est vraiment le rêve américain que je
viens de vivre puisque l'âge d'or a été
sélectionnée officiellement à la 33e
édition de ciné Quest où il a été
projeté deux fois le film a vraiment
reçu le succès que j'attendais auprès du
public l'étape des festivals est
vraiment crucial parce que d'une
certaine manière elle peut permettre
d'ajuster aussi la promotion du film en
fonction des retours mais aussi elle
permet tout simplement d'élargir le
public du film en discussion avec les
distributeurs pour que l'âge d'or soit
diffusé Géna sur eux rêve que son film
sorte en salle au cinéma un parcours
féerique pour cette yvinoise qui n'a pas
oublié sa terre-Natale
c'est très très important pour moi de
pouvoir montrer qu'on peut venir d'un
petit village et faire quelque chose de
grand j'ai étudié au collège Pierre de
Coubertin et après je me suis envolée
vers de nouveaux horizons et je crois
que c'est important puisque pour moi ça
reste en tant qu'artiste c'est très
important de se souvenir de ce qui était
présent depuis le début qui ont aidés
parce que la route est longue et elle
est plus belle quand on la continue
ensemble une ascension qui a demandé
beaucoup d'implication le marché du film
le marché du cinéma est extrêmement
compétitif et encore plus pour une
réalisatrice comme moi qui suis-je qui
suis une femme ça demande finalement
d'avoir beaucoup de d'amour pour son
film ce que j'ai envie de raconter c'est
c'est finalement l'histoire du film
c'est de dire que le soutien est très
important célébrer la vie est très
important et je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
y a aussi une envie de rassembler les
cultures je pense qu'il y a un besoin de
de rassembler les générations de de se
retrouver finalement et je crois que le
cinéma permet de se retrouver et
j'aimerais continuer ça trois ans après
le film continue de se faire une place
dans le monde exigeant du cinéma en
attendant un jour de pouvoir toucher les
spectateurs du monde entier
voilà ce portrait de Jena suru c'est
bien de d'essayer comme ça de faire
vivre un film quand on a des petits
moyens qu'on n'est pas très connu mais
le film retrouve peu à peu son public je
trouve ça très beau on peut faire du
cinéma et surtout le cinéma et doit être
visible pour tout le monde et accessible
à tout le monde absolument et elle voilà
parce que c'est pas facile que ces
personnes dans le milieu elle a fait
souffrir elle a réalisé c'est de la
Vallée de Chevreuse elle est originaire
de la vallée de Chevreuse et on voit que
c'est toujours un parcours du combattant
quand même ça s'appelle donc l'âge d'or
comme le film très célèbre de buz et
c'est Jenna sur rue et c'était un sujet
de Céline Charles
on va parler de quelque chose de plus
grave vous savez qu'il y a deux ans
c'était le 16 octobre était assassiné
dans des conditions absolument terrible
Samuel patic et professeurs au lycée de
Conflans
de conditions absolument effroyable et à
cette occasion pour les la commémoration
des deux ans de cette assassinat nous
rediffusions sur la chaîne un entretien
que j'avais eu avec l'écrivain David
Ninetta qui a été auteur d'une
remarquable enquête très complète sur
cette assassinat le livre il avait
publié un livre qui s'appelle g exécuté
un chien de l'enfer rapport sur
l'assassinat Samuel Paty et c'était aux
Cherche-Midi et rapport sur l'assassinat
de Samuel Patis c'était un peu une
réponse au rapport des autorités
pédagogiques qui avait fait qui avait
fait des rapports sur l'affaire Patty au
rectorat je vous propose de voir un
extrait de cet entretien dans lequel
justement
il raconte la responsabilité peut-être
des autorités
de l'éducation nationale la boucle que
je décris c'est au fond vous avez donc
la situation quelqu'un qui est pris en
charge par des islamistes
et un référent laïcité qui confirme la
thèse de l'élève qui n'est pas dans la
classe donc qu'il aurait effectivement
froisser ses élèves qui est une thèse
pédagogiquement absurde mais qui va être
c'est ça qui est incroyable qui va être
validé par le rapport de l'Inspection
Générale donc l'inspection générale
reprend la thèse du référent laïcité
donc je dirais presque valider
somnambuliquement sans se rendre compte
de la contradiction pédagogique que ça
représente parce que si effectivement
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure le
comportement d'un professeur dépend de
la sensibilité religieuse de ses élèves
il n'y a pas d'enseignement laïc
possible donc
l'inspection des générales reprend
somnambuliquement la thèse du référent
laïcité qui en plus repose sur un
témoignage qui est celle de l'élève qui
était pas dans la classe
en tout cas confirme ce faux témoignage
et va être repris somnambuliquement par
l'Éducation nationale puisque
l'éducation nationale va s'appuyer sur
ce rapport donc vous avez une boucle in
aux personnes ne s'aperçoit un que la
thèse initiale est fausse c'est-à-dire
qu'il n'a pas froissé ses élèves et deux
que le fait de lui reprocher ça est une
contradiction pédagogique
voilà c'est je vous propose de pouvez
retrouver évidemment cette entretien sur
sur l'antenne et sur le site de TV 78
et j'aurais bientôt une autre entretien
avec Didier Lemaire vous savez qui était
ce professeur de Trappes qui a été
obligé de d'arrêter de travailler parce
que dit-il il a été menacé menacé de
mort
voilà bah écoutez comme Luke boucan ma
petite aujourd'hui comme ça c'est normal
c'est le direct qui veut ça n'est pas
encore réveillé les embouteillages et
comme
notre ami qui fait le tour Xavier
Thévenard
la ligne n'est pas n'est pas correcte
donc on peut pas on la voit
contacter peut-être pour la 5G le vélo
il faudra il faudrait que vous nous
fassiez occuper un sacré ça
irait plus facilement je vous rappelle
peut-être demain quand même oui est-ce
qu'il fait toujours beau demain
après-midi alors demain matin demain
matin c'est mitigé le matin il y a des
petits des petites pluies ou température
moyenne 15 16 degrés selon les endroits
des Yvelines mais alors tout d'un coup
vous fermez le parapluie et ça
s'améliore l'après-midi et là on va
jusqu'à 19 et 20 degrés c'est pas les
sommets des températures en France
puisqu'il y a des régions dans votre
région par exemple Nicolas
sur la plage la Côte des Basques à
Biarritz par exemple
c'est vrai merci à tous les deux merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis à très vite
pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8
[Musique]